president biden wasted no time barring
air travel from eight african countries
as the u.s assesses the new coronavirus
strain that was identified in south
africa the restrictions start on monday
and apply to non-u.s residents ouija
chang is on nantucket island
massachusetts where the president is
spending thanksgiving weekend ouija good
morning
good morning to you jeff and good
morning to everybody just one day after
declaring america is back president
biden had to acknowledge this potential
new setback with the armacron variant
and as u.s and south african officials
scramble to determine just how
infectious it is the president is once
again pleading with americans to get
vaccinated
president biden said he decided to put
new air travel restrictions in place
after meeting with his coven response
team for half an hour on friday starting
on monday travelers from south africa
and seven other countries won't be
allowed to enter the u.s but the policy
does not apply to american citizens or
permanent residents
we don't know a lot about the variant
except that it is a great concern it
seems to
spread rapidly one big question whether
the current vaccines offer protection
against the omicron strain dr anthony
fauci the president's chief medical
advisor said researchers are in the
process of finding out right now we're
getting the material together with our
south african colleagues to get a
situation where you could actually
directly test it so right now you're
talking about sort of like a red flag
that this might be an issue but we don't
know
president biden is dealing with the news
from nantucket where he's spending the
thanksgiving break with his family
holiday shopping and attending christmas
events he said the emergence of the new
covet variant emphasizes the importance
of being vaccinated and urged all
americans to get their booster shots
every american has not been vaccinated
should be responsible to be vaccinated
from age five years enough number one
number two
everyone eligible for the booster shot
should get the booster shot
immediately upon being eligible
that is a minimum that everyone should
be doing and i you know we always talk
about whether this is about freedom i
think it's a patriotic responsibility
president biden also urged other
countries to waive intellectual
protections for the coveted vaccine so
their formulas can be shared and widely
manufactured everywhere he said this
development reiterates the importance of
the world moving quickly dana
we do another reminder it is a global
pandemic thank you ouija